hi guys in today's video I am going to
show you how to install Ubuntu on
communities communities is an open
source platform used for deployment and
management of containers so let's get
started now the first step is to install
the necessary dependencies using two of
the commands first is sudo apt-get
update which gets all the updates
[Music]
and then you have to enter a password so
this will take a few seconds
that's done the next step is to install
app transport HTTP this is basically
used to make repositories while HTTP so
let's go ahead with that sudo
okay that's done going ahead the next
thing we have to do is to install the
docker dependency using the command sudo
apt installed okaaay Oh
you have to choose why
and this will take a few minutes
you
okay that's that so after installing the
docker we have to start and enable the
docker using the command sudo systemctl
start docker and sudo systemctl and even
though
so now the Dockers anyway so now we are
done with the first step of installation
the next step is we have to install the
necessary components for communities
before that we have to install the curl
come on
because when command is used to send
data using a URL syntax let's install
the curl command using the command sudo
apt-get install go
[Music]
so you have to select why and this will
take few minutes so moving on the next
step we have to do is download an ad key
for kubernetes installation from a URL
so let's go ahead with that pseudocode
so this is where we get the key and then
we have to add it using sudo apt key app
and it's done so the next step is we
have to add a repository in a certain
location so before doing that we have to
change the permission of that file so we
do that using C or so do chmod command
[Music]
okay so the power machine has changed
now let's go ahead and save this file in
that location first we have to enter
this command into the file this is a URL
save us
so we have to save it in this location
let's rename this to open it is dot list
now let's see
okay so here it is now moving forward
now we have to check for any updates
available
in the next command we are gonna install
the kubernetes components that is
cubelet cubed Ian Q Bechtel and
kubernetes EMM so let's go ahead with
that
so this is going to take a few minutes
now that's done so the next step we have
to initialize the master node and to do
this we have to first use a swap off
command to disable the swapping on other
devices so let's do that sudo swap off -
II now let's go ahead with the
initialization sudo Q ATM in it this is
going to take a few minutes
you
okay so before going to the next step to
start the cluster we have to use these
three commands let's just copy-paste it
okay that's done so moving forward the
next step is to deploy paths using the
following come on
you
now the pots have been deployed to a
network to see all the pots you have to
use the command sudo cubic to get false
[Music]
they concede the positive we deploy and
that brings me to the end of this demo I
hope you found it helpful thank you for
watching
hi there if you liked this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here